hello everyone and welcome to game four
of ala's race to the candidates it just
finished where he has the black pieces
against former opponent andreev um uh
French Grandmaster and it's a really
wild game you guys will love this one
let's check it out and we'll see what
what is happening and how how close alza
is to actually qualifying for the
candidates tournament so uh for this
game Andre opened with Knight to F3 he
started off with a reti and after Knight
to F6 and C4 H transport into the
English we have Pawn to B6 ala goes for
a sort of a queen's Indian setup here
Knight to C3 and Bishop to B7 uh we have
Pawn to D4 and now Pawn to E6 the
so-called casparo variation of the uh
Queen's Indian defense we have Pawn to
A3 and now Pawn to D5 striking in the
center C captures Knight captures and
now Queen to C2 we have Bishop D7 all
been play before nothing new Here pawn
to E4 captures captures uh and Knight to
D7 uh we have Bishop to D3 preparing to
Castle King Side Pawn to C5 striking in
the center and now castles we have Rook
8 to C8 uh going after the queen on C2
and of course Queen to E2 uh we have
castles and now Rook to D1 and uh here
there are a couple of games that reach
this position so it's still a fairly
long territory and Anish giri even
tweeted this position on Twitter or X
now and he said that this is actually
exciting curious if ala will withstand
the pressure of the moment white has a
Kasparov style setup uh with good
attacking prospects so let's see how
Andre uses these prospects we have Queen
to C7 bya and now there are a couple of
games again that reach this like E5 is a
know move here A4 is a known move here
Bishop to B2 is a old move here but here
we have Bishop to E3 and it is now as of
move 14 that we have a completely new
game so okay Knight to F6 ala puts more
pressure on this center now he's
threatening to win a pawn and just
Knight to D2 uh Andre defends the pawn
uh Rook F to d8 and now Pawn to F3 so
not the D4 Pawn is nicely defended ala
decides to REM maneuver the Knight
Knight D7 he wants to go Knight to B8
and Knight back to C6 uh and here we
have Pawn to A4 uh Knight to B8 and now
Pawn to F4 he starts the advancement uh
here maybe you could have considered
some other ideas like Pawn to A5 or or
REM maneuver this Knight to a better
square but he starts the advance right
away Pawn to F4 and now
gets a chance to minimize this wonderful
Center White has you can see that it's
it's marvelous captures captur and now
Knight to C6 putting pressure on that D4
Pawn so Knight to F3 adding a Defender
and now Knight to B4 attacking the light
Square Bishop here and the L's position
is already uh quite impressive because
you can't really deal with this bishop
like if you play Bishop to B1 to control
the Knight which is something you would
usually do uh the you've disconnected
your Rooks and here Queen to C3 is a
real problem for white so here instead
we have Rook eight to C1 first attacking
the black queen queen B8 and only now
Bishop to B1 but now ala just goes
Bishop to C6 and he's threatening to
pick up the A4 Pawn H there's no way to
actually defend the pawn if you try to
sacrifice it to mess up Black's Pawn
structure okay you've messed up the pawn
structure but it's still a pass pawn and
the Bishops will nicely escorted down
the board so instead we have Pawn to D5
it's um uh it's a very nice POS
positional Pawn sacrifice one that you
would expect from a player like Kasparov
to sacrifice the D Pawn to close the D
file and then to play E5 to open up this
diagonal and the path towards the black
king so let's see how this goes e
captures on D5 is objectively best but
it's maybe uh you know maybe too
dangerous like E5 now Bishop captures on
e4 Now Pawn to E6 already it looks um it
looks like quite a lot like you could
even uh take the Rook here but it's it
it looks dangerous so ala wants to play
it safe he plays Bishop captures on A4
now still puts pressure on The Rook on
D1 so Rook to F1 and now Rook captures
on C1 we have Bishop captures and now e
captures on D5 and of course Pawn to E5
opening up this diagonal so now white
does have some attacking chances he does
have the bishop PA the Knight might come
to G5 the queen might come to H5 E6 will
be played and ala is up a pawn uh sorry
up two pawns and uh If he if he can
defend and if he can start pushing those
pawns then of course he will win the
game so let's see how ala does it he
plays Queen to C8 uh he wants to have
control over D5 square but more than
that he wants to play Queen to C4 and or
or for a queen trade if the Queens come
off the board then that's pretty much it
uh we have Bishop to E3 or if you try
Knight to D4 then again just Queen to C4
is very nice um it's a it's a tough move
to meet so here Bishop to E3 is played
also prevents some checks from the from
the black queen but still Queen to C4 is
um uh sort of best here but ala went
Bishop to C5 and now what do you play
here with white it's a it's a terrible
position for white and even with with
engine perfect play uh White will still
lose this game just to give you an
example Knight to D4 is the top move
recommended by the engine sort of giving
you uh the control over F5 uh but after
something like Knight to C6 it's not
easy Knight to F5 will come now Pawn to
D4 and after we move the bishop Pawn to
G6 and it's even even this is possible
like Knight to H6 check King to G7 and
F5 you can sacrifice the Knight King
captures and you can even close off the
black king with something like F6 uh
there's just no way to reach the black
king it looks like it you should be able
to do it because all of ala's pieces
would be on the queen side uh but that's
the reality there just isn't as black
can now play uh something like Knight
captures on E5 try to give back material
and then bring the queen to G4 and the
black is perfectly safe or if you try
Queen to D2 with check you can even move
the king uh down the board King H5 is
fine also G5 is fine and if you try to
attack it then again Queen G4 and black
defense there's just um no way to to
continue the attack Black's position is
just that strong and you can see that
how how difficult it is to uh to attack
on the king side because black controls
the center you know always the side that
controls the center gets to attack so
here um Andre tried something else he
played Bishop captures on H7 check it's
a different kind of sacrifice King
captures and now Knight to G5 with check
hoping to get Queen H5 and queen to H7
alza played King to G8 and now Pawn to
E6 now rushing with Queen here doesn't
really do all that much so he played
Pawn to E6 first and you can see that
he's already down to a minute and 20
seconds on the clock whereas alza has
some 11 minutes and 48 seconds we have
Bishop captures on E3 ala decides to
eliminate one of the attackers before
deciding how to how to uh you know kill
the attack uh Queen captures on E3 also
stops the queen from easily reaching the
H7 square and now just F captures on E6
and there really isn't all that much you
can do queen to H3 is played sort of
putting pressure on E6 but really going
for Queen to H7 and there is a a winning
move here for ala only one but it's not
that difficult to spot I'm sure you guys
will see it right away so feel free to
pause the video and win the game for ala
uh while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this
tricky maneuver and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
to C2 that's the move it is it is
essential to stop um the advancement of
the queen to to H7 and of course you
don't want to do it with the queen
because then you give up the E6 Pawn so
Bishop to C2 is the move and now there's
just no continuation here F5 was played
but it doesn't really do all that much
the idea is okay if you if you capture
on F5 then you have Queen to H7 H but if
you capture with the bishop then you
really have nothing so it's really um a
last resort maybe if ala blunders with e
captures on F5 but alza just played
Queen to C5 with check and he was in
this position on move 33 that andreev
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here problem is once you
move of course Bishop captures on F5
will be played and that's it the H7
square is covered and even if you try to
get some sort of a Perpetual here with
some Queen F7 Queen H5 action uh just
rook f8 and that's it there's no move
here for for white uh so alza is
currently on four out of four what does
this mean for his journey to the candada
this tournament this means that tomorrow
he's facing his strongest opponent in
this tournament Sergey fedoruk a strong
Ukrainian Grandmaster and um if he wins
the next game he will overtake Wesley in
the live ratings he will I believe he
will play both games regardless of
whether he wins the next game or not uh
but um yeah that's that's um currently
what's happening so so we'll we'll be
following we'll see what happens will
ala overtake Wesley uh in the in the you
know via the rating spot or will will
Sergey fedoruk have something to say
about that uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it very nicely
done by Ala I would like to thank
Gregory Novak Ken Kenneth fum John
dogale Ian Sterling and Nikola wiic for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and everything
else that's happening in the Chess World
as as you can see quite a lot is
happening uh see you
soon